[موسيقى]
بعد أكثر من 100 عام ، وصل دليل ميشلين
أخيرًا إلى دبي للمرة الأولى
في الشرق الأوسط حيث منحوا 69
مطعمًا في المدينة مع مجموعة متنوعة
من الجوائز.
دبي هي الخطوة الأولى لرجل ميشيغان
في الشرق الأوسط نحن فخورون
وسعداء بإصدار هذا الاختيار الأول ، لذا فإن
نجمة واحدة للمطعم 11 ستكشف
عن الحيوية وعلى الرغم من
الإمكانات الحقيقية لدبي كنقطة ساخنة لتذوق الطعام
[موسيقى] ،
هناك جو من المؤامرات
يحيط بالجائزة على الرغم من
زيارة المفتشين للمطاعم بشكل متخفي i
لا أعرف من جاء ،
لا أعرف عندما لا أعرف حتى ما إذا
كنت هنا
ولكن ما أعرفه هو أنهم تناولوا
وجبة جيدة ،
اسمي شيف أكومالاوا ،
مؤسس الحريق غير القانوني
بعد ستة أشهر فقط من فتحهم
دخل مطعم Doors akamal في
الدليل فائزًا بنجمة واحدة وحقق
نجمة ميشلين حلمًا أصبح حقيقة عندما
كنت في أيام شبابي في
سنغافورة بدأ والداي هذا المتجر
في عام 1992. كان علي مساعدتهم في تقشير
البطاطس  التقط الأطباق المتسخة من
الطاولات مع تقدمي في السن ، أردت أن
أرى العالم الذي كنت أرغب في العمل فيه في
مطبخ احترافي
أخذته رحلته إلى دبي
قبل 10 سنوات مع القليل في جيبه ولم يكن لدي
أي دليل على أنني تلقيت بعض التعليم الجيد
أو  لا ، لذلك كان الناس مترددين جدًا في
توظيفي لأول مرة مرتديًا سترة طاهٍ ،
وما زلت أتذكر
أنني ارتديت هذا الجاكيت ، فأنت
تعلم أن مثابرة أكوا تستحق الطبق الرئيسي للتزلج
اليوم ، ولديها
عدد من المطاعم في جميع أنحاء الإمارات العربية المتحدة
تشتهر جوائز ميشلين
بالاحتفال بالمطبخ الساخن ، لكن
تصميمه على إبقاء الأمور بسيطة هو الذي
أدى إلى نجاحه
عندما
اكتشف الرجال النار ، كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي
يطبخ فيها شخص ما شيئًا ، لذلك
أردت شيئًا بسيطًا للغاية
لأن عنصر النار هو أحد
مكوناته  هو أحد المكونات ، إنه
نكهة
من البدايات المتواضعة إلى
الاعتراف به بين
أشهر الطهاة في العالم لأكمال رحلته الطهوية التي
بدأت للتو في الحصول على
النجمة الأولى هي
علامة فارقة ولكن التواجد في الدليل الذي
يحافظ على الموظفين على مدار السنوات العشر
القادمة يعد علامة فارقة أخرى
[موسيقى]